continúa la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en france 24 y
hablamos ahora de economía estamos
nuevamente con venir a blandón nuestra
prevista experta àngela y cuéntenos
américa latina' en la región más
asustada económicamente por cuenta del
coi 19 con la mediana pues tras un año
de la llegada del coronavirus américa
latina y el caribe la pobreza la
desigualdad y el desempleo avanzaron a
un ritmo sin precedentes en la región
pero más allá de la desoladora cifra de
cerca de 3 millones de empresas cerradas
y un desempleo que superó el 10 por
ciento otra de las consecuencias es el
alto endeudamiento de la región veamos
en 2019 la deuda pública era cercana el
69 por ciento y en 2020 cerró en más del
79 por ciento del pib que es la suma de
toda la producción económica de los
países esto deja la región como la más
endeudada si observamos de todas las que
están en desarrollo por encima de las
naciones emergentes de asia áfrica medio
oriente y europa libra
daniela y sigue la polémica por la
reforma eléctrica en mexico recordemos
primero que hace menos de 1
es el congreso aprobó una ley que
prioriza la estatal comisión federal de
electricidad por encima de las empresas
privadas de generación
el proyecto fue polémico desde un
principio porque hay quienes dicen que
favorece la generación de energía con
combustibles fósiles en lugar de otros
más amigables con el medio ambiente la
semana pasada un juez detuvo los efectos
de esa ley tras resolver dos acciones de
empresas generadoras de energía eólica y
pidió una revisión a fondo de la misma y
esto no le gustó al presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador que ahora escaló el
tema a los altos tribunales escuchemos
solicito que el consejo de la judicatura
lleve a cabo una investigación
para esclarecer la actuación del juez
gómez fierro en este episodio alrededor
de este asunto actúan personas
organizaciones y empresas afines al
antiguo régimen que en función de sus
conocidos intereses económicos y
políticos tenían como modus operandi la
corrupción y el influyentismo daniela y
la comisión europea- iniciar acciones
legales contra el unido porque porque
mire el primero de enero de londres y
bruselas formalizaron su divorcio hasta
ahí todo estaba bien pero quedaron en
que desde ese momento las mercancías que
cruzarán entre la isla de irlanda y gran
bretaña se iban a someter a controles
aduaneros a partir del primero de abril
el gobierno británico decidió extender
ese plazo unilateralmente hasta octubre
de inmediato a la comisión europea
anunció hoy la reapertura de un proceso
de infracción formal por supuesta
violación del acuerdo del break city y
le pide de paso
londinense que se retracte pero este
último sostienen que su actuación es
totalmente legal lo cierto es que a
muchas industrias británicas les ha
costado mucho adaptarse a estas nuevas
reglas en tan poco tiempo y sus ventas
están cayendo dramáticamente por lo que
la implementación de controles pues va a
seguir siendo bastante complicada en
esta zona daniela y el gobierno de
venezuela va intenta fomentar los pagos
digitales el presidente nicolás maduro
estaría presionando a los bancos para
que implementen estos sistemas de pago
que son bastante escasos en el país de
acuerdo con la agencia reuters cabe
resaltar que la hiperinflación en esta
nación provoca una escasez crónica de
efectivo y por eso se hace necesario el
presidente quiere comenzar con el
transporte público que es en donde se
gastan aproximadamente tres cuartas
partes de todo el efectivo en
circulación hace poco inició de hecho un
plan en el que el presidente que llamo
bolívar digital con el que el pasaje de
metro se puede adquirir a través de
tarjetas con pagos digitales y es que en
las mañanas es costumbre ver las largas
filas afuera de los bancos en caracas
para
un máximo de 400 mil bolívares esta suma
equivale a unos 20 centavos de dólar y
alcanzan únicamente para pagar el pasaje
de ida y de vuelta a nivel cuáles son
los indicadores de la jornada en eeuu
hubo cuarto récord o consecutivo en el
principal índice de la bolsa de nueva
york que es el dow jones de industriales
en europa hubo resultados negativos
principalmente por ejemplo de la bolsa
de madrid rompió una racha de cinco
sesiones al alza y en américa latina la
bolsa de buenos aires logró su quinto
ascenso consecutivo y la cita al día
daniela 104 por ciento creció la
actividad económica en brasil durante
enero y esta cifra es mejor a la que
esperaba el mercado financiero liliana
bueno gracias por la información de
economía ni la y usted gracias continúen
con más en france24 punto com
[Música]